jetzt schaut einfach mal auf den
hintergrund safe der dreißigste flecke
den ich jemals gesehen habe
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der hacker shop jeden
sonntag zeige ich euch heute die
lustigsten besten und verrücktesten
hacker der letzten woche zu beginn
wollte ich euch nochmal drei regeln
mitgeben die unbedingt erfüllen müsst um
in der hacker schon dabei zu sein
die regeln sind im video im 16 9-format
die erste regel das heißt keine
schwarzen balken die zweite regel ist
keine lex also eher video muss für sich
darauf ein drittens ist eigentlich ein
doppel regel der hacker konnte unbedingt
lustig sein also keine standard killer
auch oder sowas anders muss es
besonderes sein wenn ihr was besonders
hatte eigentlich chancen damit drastisch
dass er in die schau rein kommt und
keine anwendung das sind die vier regelt
also keine schwarzen balken keine lex
keine einwendungen von euch und viertens
und das ist ganz besonders wichtig
lustiges material keine standard ecx
okay soweit zu den regeln wenn ihr das
einschicken wollt wie immer auf youtube
um gelistet hochladen und mit den link
per pn schicken
jetzt starten wir mit der ersten salon
die stammt von hds teil heißt hacker in
jump league alles klar
ok man die buddys teil dann schon mal
hier rein was du da für uns hast ein
bisschen bisschen sehr nach keller raus
rückwärts beat exko laufen soll es auch
brutal laut hört ja natürlich
der klassische beide heck und da kommt
der bio alter schwede
dass beide der richtig mit top speaker
hoch auf ihr schmeißt sie einer nach
unten sie gehen nach oben
beide noch schneller durch die gegend
hat der despot extrem stellt das habe
ich auch selbst noch nie gesehen
normalerweise dies bei
gute reise mit dem blog wo sie schreiben
tat geklettert ja das stimmt leute jetzt
wieder bis ins special zeig was du nicht
drauf hast dieser bereiche mark smith
wird schön zeigt alles klar und ein
jogger skater klassiker natürlich und
ich glaube das macht mittlerweile echt
viel los angeles also ja ein jetski
finde ich echt eine ehre die tatsache
dass leute quasi meinen namen so mit dem
hacken verknüpfen oder mit dem hacker
basten das finde ich super league wird
immer drauf jetzt achte man darauf jetzt
fehlt ja irgendwie die wand hoch so
alles klar
ins q2 den chat der einen stadt hätte
bizkit oder the dawn lecks bei dir
dreister bastard bewerb wenn man blick
drauf leute wie immer schreibt auch
meine kommentare waren das lex oder
vielleicht keine lex vielleicht war es
auch hacks statex hier nun mal ein
kurzes exempel lecks oder hacks der
katholik wie man bei euch so viele von
dieser einsendung wir springen zur
nächsten so leute die nächsten sendung
stammt von falke fx und er schreibt hex
mit ski oder auch nicht wegducken
auszuführen es heißt okay es ist ihm der
bundesrat über ein kurzfristiges texture
pack 1000 leute sind komische socket
face in der das ding das kolleg des
gerade und was ist es das ist ich habe
da ich hab keine ahnung na klar es ist
der gute alte playtech wer hat die nicht
vermisst leute ganz ehrlich wer hat ihn
nicht vermisst der beyblade ist zurück
und er rastet aus des todes er macht
einfach wieder den dance ganz ad
oder die täter vor alter schwede dies
schreibe erzähle ich war so eine sache
da würde ich definitiv marlies
hinschreiben jetzt schauen einfach hin
der typ ist alles egal
er dreht sich immer weiter da kommt die
gift vorstadt kommt die lage dreht sich
weiter wurde noch nicht aber ich langsam
wahrscheinlich wie lava infiniti
heckroth ever 1 auf jeden fall ist
definitiv kursen kommen warum auch immer
porsche und der dance oder dance oder
dance dance dance über weiter und kriegt
rohdes aufn sack verpackt einfach total
wie schlecht der typ ist miss
auszuprobieren
es war dazu aufzufordern für uns total
okay alles klar
ok hacker da draußen viele softworks 23
der traktor durch die lava und lebt
leben der hacker lifestyle alles klar
die nächste 1 sendung stammt von flex
der war ja schon mal hektisch oder aber
ich glaub letzte woche heute hat er
wieder der einsendung wieder hsg spieler
schon mal öfters und wir gucken mal was
er für uns hat alles klar ein flüchtiger
bisher nicht die gegend also nicht er
dort eigentlich fliegen durch die gegend
ich hoffe die alles klar ich hab das
aber diese buß plattform auf das ist
doch egal was kamen was war das gerade
eben weiter
der einsiedler gekillt leute was alle
ist dass man nein es ist nicht euer
ernst leuten ein camorra alter auch
leute was macht ihr denn so bespringen
zu dieser stelle nochmal leute jetzt
schaut mal auf den hintergrund ja
wahrscheinlich jetzt hacker was das
hacker oder ich will nicht mehr
alter wie schnell fliegt dieser typ
bitte und kriegen wir fall schaden wenn
er darunter dropped
junge arbeitet man bietern rhji plugin
leute wir müssen auf jeder menschen ohne
scheiß achte auf den hintergrund nein
einfach nein für mich also für mich ist
das safe der dreißigste flecke den ich
jemals gesehen habe ich weiß wie ich bei
euch es habt ihr jemals einen krasseren
fights diesen otto da gesehen wie er
durch die gegend ziehst du mir was ist
los mit der menschheit das war es weit
von dieser folge der hacker schaut es
euch gefallen hat durch mich riesig über
den daumen nach oben freuen
verbesserungsvorschläge gerne und in die
kommentare und wie immer wenn die regeln
befolgt eine einladung an mich bei
youtube dann seid ihr vielleicht bei der
nächsten folge auch dabei so das war's
mir jetzt sehr gut gefallen
bis zum nächsten mal